Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. This is module one phase six of our course, the seven phases of detoxification.
So we're going to be going through this book and obviously I'm thinking that everybody's read the book up to this point.
So you're doing this course for me to help you walk through more details of this book and more intimate help on detoxification.
That's the purpose of this course. Phase six is what I call proper elimination or proper elimination is what I call phase six.
And that's the first module, that's where we need to start.
And I always come back to this course, it's not about creating it and then leaving it.
It's going to be as new information comes up and as I want to add information, I'll be adding it.
So think of this as a living course in that sense. We're always going to be adding information, it's going to become bulkier and bulkier.
The negative of that is going to be a lot more things to go through. The positive of that is that you're going to gain a lot more information that you could be able to help yourself.
So there'll be a lot of new videos at each one of these modules, so make sure you come back to it and learn as much as you possibly can.
So proper elimination, how we're able to get rid of our wastes, that's what phase six is all about.
This little, this video is going to be a little overview of phase six.
We'll have more detailed videos at each part of phase six because phase six really is probably the most comprehensive.
It's really colon health, small intestine health, gut health, and literally we could have multiple courses just on that.
So we want to get into this as deep as we possibly can.
Now in the book I talk about things like, of just things that will help elimination like just taking magnesium, and vitamin C, and came allo, and set up, and fiber, and things like that.
These things will all help with elimination, but we don't just, let's say if I have some constipation or elimination problems, we don't just want to take magnesium.
And boy, that really helps my elimination. We do want to dig in to maybe why I have these things.
We don't want to use natural approaches just as medicine, per se.
Medical mentality is you have a symptom, you take this drug and it takes the symptom away, but did you address the reason why the symptom was there?
I mean, that goes down to our core philosophy is, yes, we want to be as natural as possible, but we still want to get to the reason why.
Then we still want to fix the root causes of things. So, I mean, I personally take magnesium, most of the daily basis, Cape Allo, multiple times a week, fiber on a daily basis.
And when I was dealing more extensively with my cancer, I was doing coffee animals much more regularly.
But you have to get to these root causes too. You have to still deal with leaky gut issues, you have to deal with food sensitivities, you have to deal with anything that's causing inflammation of your gut, you have to deal with pesticides herbicides.
You have to deal with those things too. Those are root causes that can be causing problems.
So, we don't want to just use natural things, just as a form of medication without dealing with those two.
And that's what, you know, we're just going to touch on with this video, but we're going to dig deeper on with further videos.
And I'll be adding along the way. So, stay with me and stay coming back to this course.
We're going to add a whole section on leaky gut, what that is, and treatment parameters of leaky gut, and dig it into why you have leaky gut, because there's a lot of different causes.
Probably the biggest cause of leaky gut is the consumption of foods that either you have sensitivities to, or that are genetically modified, that are causing basically antibiotic reaction in your gut.
You're gut killing your flora offsetting, your flora causing dysbiosis.
You're going to mold issues, issues and sensitivities that throw off your gut flora from medications that you may be taking.
There's just a wide variety of things that we want to get to.
And one can say a leaky gut is can be probably the most common cause of just about any disease.
Well, we deal with cancer patients in our clinic.
Sometimes they're astounded, not so much anymore, but as years go, they'd be astounded.
Why are we dealing with a gut? I have breast cancer or I have prostate cancer.
That's how most things enter your body, either through your lungs that you breathe in toxins, or through your gut that you're consuming toxins.
That's the most common way you're getting toxins in your body.
And it affects everything.
One of the standard philosophical understands of natural medicine is that you can't separate the systems like the medical profession does.
Everything is combined, and one thing causes a cascade of problems along the way.
Any kind of inflammation that is going to cause inflammation in the brain, and we could have a whole series on that as well.
And we'll talk more about that, and I'll give you some videos to help you understand that as well and to be able to deal with that as well.
But all the poisons that we're exposed to, all the chemicals that we're exposed to, you know, not only are we consuming them in our food supply, even if you're eating completely natural and completely organic, you're still exposed to these things.
These are affecting our body, these are affecting our brain, these are then affected every part of us.
So we need to understand the barriers that we have, the blood brain barrier, the gut barrier, our skin barrier, and our lung barrier in order to best be able to protect ourselves.
So when we talk about the gut, that gut barrier is a layer of epithelial tissue that is protecting everything from that's on the outside from getting it in.
Really, when we consume something and we eat something and we swallow it, it goes into our stomach and goes into our small intestine.
It's still on the outside.
Oh, it's in my body. Well, really not really. It's in a tube within your body. It still has an entered your body. You could eat something.
Let's say, yes, swallow a piece of metal, my accident ends up with a toilet the next day. It never did affect you because you didn't absorb it.
So what is absorbed and normally things, something shouldn't be absorbed, but we'll have a breakdown in that wall, that barrier of the gut.
Things get absorbed that never should have gotten absorbed that could cause major problems.
So we can do all the detoxification that we that we want and we can support the liver pathways and key late things out of our tissue and do all this stuff.
But as soon as you can dump into the gut, if it's going across a damaged wall, it's going right back into our body and we are doing us ourselves no good.
So we got to heal that wall. We got to heal that gut barrier and I got to give you a lot of different things that aren't in the book that can be helpful for you.
There's a lot of different nutrients that could be very helpful in healing the gut. Some you don't want to take if you have cancer like glutamine, but glutamine can be very healing for the gut if you don't have cancer.
So there's some things that you want to be careful of depending on if you have other cold more abilities going on, but when we're just talking about healing the gut, there's a lot of different products that we will utilize.
We don't use the clear GI because it has glutamine with our cancer patients, but we certainly use the clear SBI Protector, the Sun Spectrum, and there's just a lot of other things that we'll talk about in further videos about how to heal that wall, how to heal the gut, how to heal that barrier.
And then we've had some people that are really, really sick that have to get more drastic and then you talk about supporting the gut by doing fecal transplants.
And we will get into details on that because that's a very small percentage of the people that need to do that, but that can help rebuild your gut.
Also in this section we're going to talk about some unpleasant trees that some people don't like to talk about, and coffee animals.
Now we talk about coffee animals with our cancer patients literally on a daily basis, so we have no trouble talking about what comes out of our rectum with our cancer patients.
But, when you're not dealing with such a serious disease, many people don't want to think that they're going to do something like this.
Now I have a whole section you'll see in this module on coffee animals, and it's very important not just for really, we don't do coffee animals to help you eliminate.
We do coffee animals to help stimulate parasympathetic tone. Parasympathetic nervous system is the nervous system that controls your immune function, controls your digestive and absorption function.
It stimulates liver detoxification pathways, so all of your detoxification is under parasympathetic neurological control.
This is the neurological part of this.
Many times we talk about detoxification, people are talking about we'll take this product and eat these foods.
That's all the chemistry of it, but we can't forget the neurology of it as well.
So, understanding parasympathetic tone, stimulating your parasympathetics is very important, because a lot of times a big part of what makes a person sick is that imbalance in the nervous system, they're sympathetic dominance.
You have these two sides to this autonomic nervous system, parasympathetic and sympathetic, and you can watch the other video on that to get more details of that.
But your sympathetic is your fight or flight, and your stress, and your anxiety, how many people are dealing with that, burning the candle at both ends.
While we need to stimulate parasympathetics, coffee animals are just one way to do that, and we get into details of this.
So, in this module, you want to watch the videos, you want to come back to this module, because we'll be adding videos all the time and adding information all the time.
You want to do that with every module. You want to read the information, by spell that wrong, provided.
You want to reference the book, you want to follow the blogs, and, you know, come back and look at the information that we're going to be adding on a regular basis too.
I really want this to be a blessing to you. I want this to be a self-help to you that you...
maybe that that you won't still use a local practitioner, but maybe you could take some of this information to the local practitioner that maybe it's a piece that they don't have, that you can be able to take care of yourself.
And ultimately, I want you, I just think in the future, the more knowledge that you have and how to care for yourself, that you can dictate your own health care, I think you're going to be in better shape.
That's the whole purpose of doing all of our courses. So, we want you to be blessed by it, know that we'll be praying for you, and keep up the good work.